The levels of Douche baggish nest.
Oh my God.
Almost like sports fans are the worst.
They're the worst.
You name it after your tab
that mean to tout olds you.
It's not the fucking La Rogan's.
Right.
You know it's true.
Fucking La Lakers.
Yeah,
and they're putting out a shitty product.
Yeah.
Goddammit.
How's your season been
these last couple of years?
Wow.
What team are you?
It doesn't even matter.
The point is the Lakers suck.
Oh,
well the hell's fan.
We made it stuck around for
the first time in history.
Look at New Orleans Pelicans.
How did you get to be a fan of the,
because they started in North
Carolina when I was there.
Then they moved and then they
change your goddamn name.
It's all a mass,
but fuck my teams to stay one
a team called the Pelican,
not me.
Don't go.
The wife of the guy who owns it,
he owns a good franchise
as a fucking billionaire.
Smart Guy who makes up the fucking
living for himself and he's like,
oh,
the trophy wife.
You want to name the team?
Then all of these men
have to fucking support.
Wow.
Is that really what happened?
That's what happened to your variant.
It's fucking ridiculous.
Very upset.
What would you have called
that if you were attracting
the bath mats?
It's a better fucking
name than the Pelicans.
I had to research all the time,
but like vicious Pelican behavior
so I could get behind a little bit.
They are vicious though.
Belly ducks hole.
They'll eat ducks hole.
They'll go down there.
It's going to go fuck off.
I'm sure I could watch that.
Oh,
it's great.
I'm sure we're going to watch
hip Pelican eats a duck,
but no one thinks of that.
When you think of a Pelican,
no.
You think of like a cute
thing that brings babies.
Yeah.
Oh,
whoa.
Back that up.
We get this one.
Oof
the whole duck.
That is fucking insane,
dude.
Oh,
they're just trying to drive them off.
The other ducks mad like,
come on,
give me back.
Come on.
Dammit.
He's down.
Look,
he's just swamped to stop.
One more time.
Let me see that again.